4 de agosto dos explosiones sacudieron
el puerto de virus devastando el área y
dejando un enorme cráter de 140 metros
de ancho la onda expansiva de la
explosión rompió ventanas que gran parte
de la ciudad se llegó a sentir en chipre
el culpable dos mil 750 toneladas de
nitrato de amonio que se habían
almacenado de forma insegura en uno de
los depósitos del puerto con casi 200
muertos más de 6000 heridos y 300.000
personas sin hogar es la explosión más
destructiva en la historia del iban un
poco después los rescatistas reinaron
los escombros en busca de supervivientes
mientras que los voluntarios se unieron
para las tareas de limpieza mientras
tanto la furia pública aumentaba por la
lenta respuesta del gobierno cuando los
funcionarios libaneses prometieron una
investigación interna transparente
el presidente francés emmanuel macro
voló a beirut dos días después de la
explosión recorrió el devastado puerto y
conversó con la gente en una visita
destinada a expresar solidaridad con los
libaneses mientras tanto aparecieron
documentos que mostraban que los
funcionarios sabían sobre el peligro que
había desde hacía años y esto provocó
nuevas protestas contra el gobierno los
objetivos de la protesta fueron el
ministerio de
en exteriores y el parlamento ya que los
manifestantes acusaron a sus líderes de
corrupción y mala gestión varios días de
manifestaciones provocaron
enfrentamientos con la policía una
creciente presión pública que obligó a
renunciar al gobierno del primer
ministro hasan diab el 10 de agosto pero
díaz y sus ministros se han quedado en
funciones el presidente libanés michel
aún aseguró que la investigación sobre
las explosiones es muy compleja y no
concluirá rápidamente ha descartado la
posibilidad de una investigación
internacional pero ha agradecido la
ayuda del fbi y los agentes franceses
mientras tanto varias docenas de países
han prometido más de 250 millones de
euros para ayudar a reconstruir beirut
una ayuda destinada a eludir al gobierno
y entregarse directamente a
organizaciones benéficas locales de
confianza